the world has taught us not to think of
denial as one region but rather as like
you know you have people in North Africa
people in East Africa people in Central
East Africa and so you you don't see the
connection that the Nile gonna gives you
it started with this musical curiosity I
grew up in Egypt and I was never exposed
to the music of Ethiopia which is a
river neighbor to Egypt and how
interesting would it be for a lot of
Egyptians to become more exposed to this
music the joy of discovering each
other's traditions makes a new like I
had never heard for example a won an
instrument they called in anger and I
felt I fell in love with it the first
minute I heard it but all this time I
didn't know it existed
these instruments haven't met before
neck and and that's in the sense that
they're meeting now yeah and also like
taking traditional instruments and
making them do non-traditional things
we're creating a Nile sound we're
creating a full-on Nile sound not just
region one country by one country but
like as a river when do we sound like as
a region it's like an orchestra good
evening hello we are the Nile project we
are musicians from seven of the eleven
Nile Basin countries this is the sound
of our friendship
with music it's always an experiment in
how can we make each other sound good so
everyone is on the same page everyone is
working together towards the same goal
it's really hard to to be able to work
with other East African musicians and
other Nile Basin musicians in the region
it takes a shift of thinking to be like
oh no we actually have a lot in common
so the not project's goal is to really
engage University students through this
music we hope this tour gets students to
ask questions and to start rethinking
the Nile Basin as one ecosystem for me
being part of the Nile project it's
really about redefining our relationship
with the river itself as people and
where we feel like we are with it and
really defining our relationship with
our neighbors on that